all right let's do this how are you
folks it's me mark
Marc Maron this is WTF try not to freak
out I feel a little hazy in the mind
because the President of the United
States is on the show today you know if
I thought to myself when I was in
college that I'd be in a garage yeah a
couple miles away from where I was
living doing an interview as president
with a comedian I think that's a pretty
hard scenario to couldn't imagine it
it's not possible to imagine you know I
ran the country from my couch for a
couple years a lot of people a lot of
people do yeah I hear from them all the
time I'm a comic so the night that you
knew that they were gonna shoot bin
Laden you're doing comedy I was pretty
funny too yeah you like comedy I love
comedy and who are your guys well prior
prior wasn't a right one yeah Dick
Gregory when he was really on the edge
Seinfeld's a whole nother different type
you know I knows a buddy of yours hey I
love Louie yeah yeah I think Louis
terrific uh uh we just made his life
he's wonderful in in a such a
self-deprecating but yeah but edgy kind
of lamb and and and basically
good-hearted even when he's saying stuff
that's pretty rude yeah you know Ron
wrong in your mind you know what happens
now because this is going to go up
Monday and this is Friday so in relation
to that event that the point I made in
the immediate aftermath of the killing
on Thursday yet was that I've done this
way too often yes during the course of
my presidency it feels as if a couple
times a year yeah I end up having to
speak to the country and to speak to a
particular community about a devastating
loss and you know the grieving that the
country feels is real the sympathy
obviously the prioritizing comforting
the families all that's important but I
think part of the point that I wanted to
make was that it's not enough just to
feel bad there are actions that could be
taken to make events like this less
likely and one of those actions we could
take would be to enhance
some basic common-sense gun-safety laws
that by the way the majority of gun
owners support mm-hmm
this is unique to our country
there is no other advanced nation on
earth that tolerates multiple shootings
on a regular basis and considers it
normal to some degree that's what's
happened in this country it's become
something that we expect when you came
into office I am me I know gun owners
that there was this tremendous fear like
these are going to come for our guns you
know unfortunately the grip of the NRA
on Congress is extremely strong I don't
foresee any legislative action being
taken in this Congress and I don't
support see any real action being taken
until the American public feels a
sufficient sense of urgency and they say
to themselves this is not normal this is
something that we can change and we're
going to change it but don't you get
furious I mean I saw you on TV the other
day and I could see the anger and you're
not it you're not a boil over kind of
guy but I could feel it yeah right after
Sandy Hook
Matthew Town yeah when 26 year olds are
gunned down and Congress literally does
nothing yeah that that's the closest I
came to feeling disgusted I was pretty
disgusted you know coming from where you
came from in terms of racial relations
where are we with that in terms of when
you came in in your mind do not say that
nothing's changed when it comes to race
in America unless you lived through
being a black man in the 1950s or 60s or
70s racism we are not cured up and it's
not just a matter of it not being polite
to say in public that's not the
measure of whether racism still exists
or not it's not just a matter of overt
discrimination societies don't overnight
completely erase everything that
happened two to three hundred years
prior I was talking to somebody the
other day about why I actually think I'm
a better president and would be a better
candidate if I were running again but I
have been and it's sort of like an
athlete you might slow down a little bit
you might not jump as high as you used
to but I know what I'm doing and I'm
fearless that's such a liberating
feeling absolutely right it's one of the
benefits of of agent almost compensates
for the fact that I can't play
basketball anymore oh good all right
well thanks great to talk to there we
good we're good how's fun I appreciate
mr. president it was great all right